wow c'est vraiment fouettant
pouvez-vous m'entendre juste avoir un cri
[Musique]
Timothy vous avez appris l'italien pendant que vous
tourniez un film italien appelé
par votre nom
alors est-ce que Venise semble familier pouvez-vous
commander vos spreads oh ouais mec quelle
bonne question
tu m'as eu là
non mais je sens que l'italien m'est revenu
plus que je ne l'aurais imaginé
et euh
certainement les réponses que
j'ai encore mais non je déteste l'
admettre mais même en commandant un café je suis
probablement pouvez-vous confirmer que taylor  il
ne parle pas en italien je n'ai pas entendu
non non tu ne l'as pas fléchi autour de moi j'aurais
aimé savoir que ça allait arriver parce que
j'aurais pu casser quelque chose essayons la
dernière fois que
nous avons rencontré timothy tu étais paul  un échange pour
cette galaxie lointaine et maintenant vous êtes de retour
sur terre oui avec ce personnage lee
des années 80 personnage très étrange avec
une coupe de cheveux bizarre
moins de pouvoir
moins
de responsabilité mais toujours beaucoup de sang
oui ça faisait partie de l'attrait
de ça  le projet jouait des personnages plus grands que
nature comme paula tradies qui
sont également fondés à bien des égards
sur une suite de dunes en ce moment, mais je voulais
raconter une histoire qui concernait presque
quelqu'un qui est exactement le contraire qui est
en marge de la
société.  l'ère numérique pré-ayant
accès à l'information et vivant au jour le
jour survivant des histoires qu'il se
raconte sur lui-même et puis
quand il rencontre marin l'un par rapport à l'
autre et ce que ce serait à cette époque
d'être euh
comme si on était en convoitise  un peu tellement
isolé que vous survivez par
ce que vous vous dites au jour le jour c'est
votre deuxième expérience avec ce
réalisateur guadagnino avez-vous aidé taylor
à euh pour entrer dans son monde mec nous en
parlions hier je me sens comme
si  j'aide taylor pendant trois secondes tu
sais parce que je pense tout de suite qu'elle était
en feu
et qu'elle faisait un travail incroyable je pense que tu as
commencé avant moi
ouais je veux dire qu'il est très gentil il
m'a complètement aidé dès le
début
je n'aurais pas eu le  performance que
j'avais eue je n'ai pas été en face de Timothy
et
chaque scène que nous avons eue ensemble
j'avais vraiment l'impression qu'il
y avait tellement de croissance et d'évolution
et
c'était très spécial et ouais
j'étais un rocher pour moi vraiment comme
ouais le ferais-
tu  disons que c'est une histoire d'
amour fou comme dirait beyonce ou
ou plus qu'une mauvaise romance comme dirait lady gaga
je ne sais pas
taylor a dit quelque chose de vraiment beau
hier qui était
que l'amour peut
me corriger si je me trompe amour  pourrait
accorder ou permettre à quelqu'un de trouver
sa solitude quelque chose à cet effet
le protecteur de sa solitude aimer
quelqu'un c'est être le protecteur
de la solitude donc de cette façon nous voulons tous
nous voulons tous vivre au-delà d'un
amour fou mais je pense  c'est plus sur
ouais l'amour de la protection de la
terre
d'être si jeune et si peu sûr
et si dégoûté de soi au moins pour lee
que lorsque vous trouvez quelqu'un qui
vous accorde cette capacité à vous regarder dans le
miroir et à ne pas vous détester, c'est le
premier cadeau que je  pense que l'amour peut vraiment t'apporter tu
sais juste montrer que tu peux être
aimé ce qui est vraiment spécial dans ce
film c'est qu'ils sont dans ce genre de
conteneur ensemble dans lequel il n'y a pas
beaucoup de jugement le cas échéant
et
euh surtout à ce moment de leur
vie  c'est très important et la croissance et
l'apprentissage
qu'ils
tiennent vraiment cet espace l'un pour l'autre
euh je ne sais pas si tout le monde a ça
dans la vie et
euh c'est beau de le voir dans celui-ci
à l'écran
car je peux t'entendre littéralement euh perdu ton
français
non  non pas
d'italiens
d'accord mais auriez-vous besoin d'un coach français
pourriez-vous envisager de m'avoir oh ouais
ouais absolument absolument
merci
[Musique]